كما يظهر الان امامكم بالفعل بدا
المواطنين الهنود بالصعود الى الطائره من
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده سوف
يغادرها هؤلاء الرعايه بعد ان تم اجلائهم
من مدينه بورتسودان الى مدينه جده يستعدون
للمغادره الى مدينه احمد اباد الهنديه على
متن هذه الطائره 231 مواطن هندي بعد ان تم
اجلؤه من قبل سلطه السلطات السعوديه هنالك
في السودان الى مدينه جده وعلما ان هذه هي
الرحله الخامسه منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء او
المغادره من جده او مغادره الرعايه من جده
الى المدن الهنديه نتحدث على عدد يصل
كاجمالي قرابه
1415 مواطن هندي من الرعايه الهنود الذين
تم اجلاؤهم من ميناء بورد سودان الى مدينه
جده يغادرون الى مدينه كوتش الهنديه
ومدينه اسلام اباد والعاصمه الهنديه ايضا
لا تزال عمليات
مستمره من ميناء بورت سودان الى جده وكذلك
هنالك رحلات تغادر مدينه جده بعد ان تم
استقبال الرعايه وتقديم كافه الخدمات لهم
ومنحه ومنحهم التاشيره استثنائيه لمده شهر
تعمل السفارات هنا لانهاء اجراءات رعاياها
حتى يستطعون مغادره السعوديه مبكرا
لوصولهم الى بلدانهم المتوقع او في تمام
الساعه السابعه صباحا اي بعد كم ساعه من
بعد اربع ساعات من الان سوف يغادر قرابه
المئه وخمسه وثمانين مواطن صيني الى
العاصمه الصينيه على متر الخطوط الجويه
الصينيه كما نشاهد تم انها تم استقبال
هؤلاء الرعايه هنا في مجمع صلاه الحج
والعمره وفي توديعهم من قبل اداره مطارات
جده وعدد من القطاعات الامنيه والحكوميه
للتاكد من تدليل كافه الصعوبات وتقديم
التكافه التسهيلات حتى يغادرها هؤلاء
الرعايه الى بلدانهم بعد ان تم استقبالهم
الحلوى في قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه اليوم
ها هم اليوم يغادرون بالورود وبالحلوى في
توديعهم من قبل ادارات مطارات جده ومن قبل
المديريه العامه للجوازات وعدد من
القطاعات الحكوميه العامله في مطار مطارات
اجده ايضا نتحدث انه عمليات الاجلاء تزال
مستمره كما اشار السفير السعودي في
الخرطوم انا تزال عمليات الاجلاء من ميناء
بورت سودان الى مدينه جده تحديدا للقاعه
الملك فيصل البحريه او حتى الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي او حتى كذلك عبر الجسر
الجوي الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
نتحدث عن جنسيات كبيره ومتعدده حتى هذه
اللحظه تجاوز عدد الرعايه من قامت باجلاء
من الحكومه السعوديه واصمن ميناء بورت
سودان وصولا الى جده قرابه او تجاوز
5197 شخص من 100 جنسيه اجنبيه مختلفه تم
استقبالهم في مدينه جده وانهاء اجراءاتهم
وتسكينهم في اربعه فنادق ضخمه في جده وبعد
ذلك يتم انهاء السفر الخاصه بهم حتى يتسال
لهم العوده الى بلدانهم كما نشاهد الان ها
هم الرعايه الهنديين او الهنود بعد وصولهم
الى جده قضوا قرابه 48 ساعه ها هم يستعدون
الان لمغادره مدينه جده وصولا الى مدينه
احمد اباد الهنديه في رحله سوف تستغرق
قرابه السته الساعات من مدينه جده عبر
طائره الباص ثري تابع الخطوط الهنديه
وايضا لا تزال الرحلات الاجلاء او
المغادره من جده مستمره من المتوقع خلال
الساعات القادمه ايضا مغادره رحله الصينيه
هذه هي الرحله الخامسه الهنديه التي تغادر
مدينه جده نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره من
الرعايه وغادرون تدريجيا عبر المنفذ الجوي
الاول هنا في جده والاكبر هو مطار الملك
خالد الدولي بجده نعم لمتابعه المزيد نهر
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات